[Musica]
salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione che la prima recensione del
2012 anche se effettivamente non è il
primo video dell'anno perché ho già
fatto un blog nel secondo canale che
potete vedere come video risposta di
questa recensione quindi possiamo
iniziare subito il film che voglio
recisi re oggi enrique io ho anche
conosciuto come the story of righi un
film del 1991 diretto da alan kay kay
richio è tratto da un manga
violentissimo creato nel 1983 da lo
leggo se non me lo ricorderò mai
masahiro tar caio e salutari e giulia da
cui è stata tratta anche una serie
animata ma partiamo subito con la trama
attenzione ve lo dico subito questo film
contiene una quantità spropositata di
scene violente che siano fatte male o
che siano fatte bene non importa io vi
avverto lo stesso quindi più sensibili
sono avvisati
il film parte con uno strano inizio si
vede il nostro protagonista entrare in
una prigione passando per il
metaldetector che gli rileva che asse
non se lo ricordasse dei proiettili nel
petto anche se non ci spiega subito come
ci sono finiti lì magari ha un piercing
poco fashion scopriamo subito che la
prigione è gestita da quattro pericolosi
criminali nei rispettivi punti cardinali
7 pari del tour four way it quest ix
enza it rains controlled by al lille
però nel bagno intanto dei brutti ci
danno una dimostrazione di quanto
pericolosa sia la prigione picchiano un
vecchio perché ha osato dire
l'asciugamano è mio
o mio dio davvero un asciugamano e
pazzesco ma come se non bastasse gli
rompono in testa anche il giocattolo che
aveva costruito per il figlio ci rubano
un asciugamano e ti rompo le giocattoli
in testa sono i più brutali criminali
sulla faccia della terra ma dai ma
neanche i bulli di una scuola elementare
[Applauso]
o dio li hanno grattugiato la faccia
ovviamente la sicurezza non fa nulla per
fermare tutto ciò ma ecco che arriva
ricchi che come un incredibile sgambetto
lo fa inciampare e piantare su un pezzo
del giocattolo
eccolo lì notare il pupazzone fintissimo
che hanno messo al posto dell'attore
anche sapendo che è finto non so perché
ma tutto ciò non fa che aumentare la
stranezza che aleggia in tutto il film
si scopre che il tizio con la faccia
inchiodata è chiamato killer del braccio
nord uno dei boss della prigione e ora
per vendicarsi vuole liberare drago
pazzo un bestione incatenato in
isolamento
praticamente il buddha delle arti
marziali subito dopo al vecchio di prima
viene negata la libertà vigilata quindi
decide di impiccarsi e farla finita
secondo me si è suicidato perché gli ha
rubato l'asciugamano poi non lo so
mentre portano via al cadavere lì chi
porge gli ultimi saluti
ma da dove l'ha tirato fuori il trenino
e sfoga la sua rabbia sotto la pioggia
[Musica]
e mentre si fa la doccia arrivano drago
pazzo e il killer del braccio nord
america news
[Applauso]
[Musica]
santo cielo che figata
voglio provare una cosa vediamo se ci
azzecco
[Musica]
cesa
grazie
riportano ricky in cella i proiettili
nel petto si fanno sentire
parte così un flashback in cui si vede
ricchi allenarsi con suo zio cost giusto
per farvi capire quanto è esagerato
questo film lo zio per allenarlo gli
tira addosso delle lapidi di pietra
jackie chan a confronto sei una pippa
ritornato in prigione viene portato dal
vicedirettore un buongustaio con uno
vicino al posto della mano sinistra è un
occhio di vetro che inizia interrogare
il povero ricky nell'unica maniera
possibile in questo film picchiandola
sangue e un samuel e lo minaccia
facendogli vedere la foto di una ragazza
lui cara si chiude qui per pec che ha
[Musica]
la stropicciata e finita
ve l'ho detto che non dovevi farlo
subito dopo passano delle scene a caso
con persone poco importanti certo che
benissimo un film di arti marziali barra
splatter parlano un po troppo
[Musica]
you that may ha appunto il vicedirettore
decide così di vendicarsi di chi dicendo
al capitano della sicurezza di darsi da
fare
[Musica]
c'è chi ha promesso
come scusa ma progetti a presenza questa
è senza ombra di dubbio la più bella
scena mai girata nella storia della
cinematografia un uomo con un uncino e
un occhio di vetro con dentro delle
mentine erezione erezione ovviamente
artistica
quest'uomo ha vinto tutto e finalmente
combattono in questo angolo abbiamo il
tatuatore del braccio nord in
quest'altro angolo abbiamo rikyel detto
che i siro per ovvi motivi i lottatori
partono con dei semplici pugni finché il
tatuato non estrae un coltello e tira in
faccia di chi una polverina brillante
cosa vorrebbe fare farlo volare
nell'isola che non c'è
[Musica]
o dio devo smetterla di chiedere come
farà a combattere da cieco
roba in house ma il nostro dove non
demorde e colpendo un tombino riesce a
lavarsi gli occhi ma ecco la reazione
[Musica]
troppo poco
io consiglio adesso di metterci un
occhio che dispensa noccioline ora devo
farvi vedere una scena un pochettino
forte copritevi gli occhi se siete delle
fighette cioè come me alla fine si legga
i tendini per chiudere la ferita chadli
al confronto sei un barbapapà e adesso
una delle scene più malate del film ma
anche una delle più famose il tatuatore
si apre la pancia tira fuori le budella
e tenta di strozzare l'avversario
fallisce ma non demorde si lancia
all'attacco mari chi lo prende lo lancia
e al volo lo colpisce con un pugno e gli
spacca al cranio
[Musica]
salve
che succede no nulla sei sono morto cosa
già e come hai presente che tu dici
sempre mi verrà un infarto a guardare
questo film è arrivato
hai visto la scena più trash mai fatta
si sa si è adesso e ora ti devo far
tornare in vita perché non hai ancora
finito 3 2 1
la battaglia si è conclusa ma dal nulla
arrivano i tre lottatori mancanti che da
un lato web
il top player
io questa cosa la adoro si vede che è
tratto da un manga i classici
combattimenti di livello crescente fino
ad arrivare al boss finale ricky intanto
fa la conoscenza di un ragazzo intento a
far suonare una foglia quindi è
dimostrato che anche in un film del
genere c'è spazio per scene leggermente
più serie ma dal pubblico sale un grido
chi se ne frega
dopo aver visto questo ne voglio ancora
voglio di violenza gratuita fatta beffe
di speciali malandati non sto proprio
benissimo però anche perché è giusto
cinque secondi dopo questo ragazzo viene
scudettato
[Musica]
bene questo ovviamente porta alla
vendetta
purtroppo il combattimento dura pochi
secondi perché vengono interrotti da
tarzan
no non è un nomignolo che gli ho dato io
si chiama proprio tarzan nel film che
blocca di chi in una presa con le
braccia in seguito lo porta in una cella
di isolamento che pian piano si riempie
di cemento
[Musica]
un sacco di cose a caso ricky si libera
e sfonda la porta con un tuffo
finché fate le porte di carta velina per
forza e siccome le cose a caso non
vengono mai da sole arriva al direttore
del carcere in persona insieme al puff
utimo figlio
[Musica]
prendo fiato e vi descrivo la scena
arriva al direttore il figlio è uno
stronzo inciampa da solo il direttore si
incazza accusano un tizio che passava da
tutt'altra parte di averlo fatto cadere
il direttore lo acceca il figlio e gli
fa la linguaccia stronzo ricky si libera
dalla sua armatura di cemento e
acchiappa direttore ma tarzan sfondo una
parete e lo blocca legandolo con le
sbarre della cella mentre il direttore
guarda compiaciuto visto quante cose a
caso ci sono in una scena di due minuti
tipo 20 è un film fantastico comunque
tarzan e inizia a picchiarlo senza pietà
ricky si libera e finalmente inizia al
combattimento il nuovo avversario e
tarzan 130 kg di muscoli e capelli
parte subito con un pugno che viene
bloccato dal nostro eroe spezzandogli un
braccio senza perdere tempo ricchi di
piante un pugno in bocca
[Applauso]
letteralmente
[Musica]
e già che c'era gli spappolò anche una
mano
bruce lee al confronto se un
collezionista di francobolli ma i casini
e le scene senza una logica non sono
ancora finite infatti ora il soffitto
inizia a scendere rischiando di
schiacciare ricky
no no cioè mi tutti perché mai dovrebbe
esserci una prigione un intero soffitto
tipo pressa che cade e schiaccia tutto
quello che c'è sotto
a cosa serve che cosa ci dovrebbero fare
con una cosa del genere dei biscotti per
godzilla
egli però viene catturato e fatto
sotterrare vivo una palata di terra alla
volta da tutti i carcerati rimpiazzare
[Musica]
ma quanto è malato il direttore di
questo carcere
le regole sono se riesce a sopravvivere
per sette giorni incastrato nel terreno
lo lasciano vivere durante questo
periodo si vedono altri flashback in cui
si scopre che i proiettili nel petto
arrivano da una faida creata per una
donna non potrei annoiarmi più di così
ovviamente dopo sette giorni lui è
ancora in vita ma non lo lasciano andare
comunque o mio dio che colpo di scena
non me lo sarei mai aspettato ma grazie
all'aiuto degli altri prigionieri viene
liberato e scatta la rivolta
il vicedirettore viene mutilato senza
pietà e che ora potrebbe mettersi un
erogatore di panna montata
mi hanno tagliato anche l'altra mano
arriva la polizia sono botte per tutti
[Applauso]
lì chi va dal direttore per vendicarsi
di tutto quanto ma prima deve
sconfiggere belli capelli e quell'altro
uno viene fatto esplodere in un forno
l'altro perde una gamba cose
normalissime ma ecco il momento del
giudizio la resa dei conti però un
momento non potete vedere anche voi il
direttore non sa le arti marziali come
potrebbe mai combattere contro league
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
grazie
sì
[Applauso]
sono morto di nuovo vero già merda solo
che queste cose sono la quintessenza del
pattume il mio cuore non resiste è lo
vedo devi stare attento
lo so dai dai che manca poco la
rimandano indietro che finisco ok dai
e il finale vede da una parte ricky
sempre più scassato e dall'altra un
direttore incazzato di 250 kg minimo
volano pugni da tutte le parti
ricky sembra soccombere ai pugni di
questo abominio
ma lui il protagonista del film quindi
non può perdere proprio sul contratto
c'è scritto parte gli pianta un pugno
nello stomaco nello è la parola chiave e
dopo un gancio nelle palle lo acchiappa
e lo butta nel tritacarne
come se non bastasse lo spinge giù
sempre più forte finché il direttore non
diventa una poltiglia il tutto finisce
sotto una pioggia di sangue
alla fine riprende la testa la fa vedere
a tutta la prigione
la lancia in segno di disprezzo corre
verso un muro e lo sfonda con un solo
buio facendo fuggire tutti
[Musica]
steven seagal no niente torna a cura a
dormire va
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ride
[Musica]
quindi questo era a rischio
veramente un sacco di gente mi ha
chiesto di recessivo però me l'hanno
chiesto da recensire in modo negativo
perché è uno dei film trash più belli
che esistano in questo momento essendo
un film trash ma di quelli belli ho
pensato lo metto come so bad it's good
man o perché è intenzionalmente 3 cm
si vede che è fatto apposta così
esagerato e così violento probabilmente
perché tratto dal manga il manga non
l'ho mai letto quindi non so come sia
però credo sia questi livelli
io vi consiglio di guardarlo lo so è
molto violento ma è talmente tanto
violento che alla fine vi abituate
io come al solito vi ringrazio di tutti
gli iscritti tutti i commenti tutti i
complimenti che mi fate e ci vediamo ad
una prossima recensione
già già già
già